[Music]
eating is already our favorite part of
the day and the reason why we wake up in
the morning so just imagine how happy
these people were when they discovered
that they won the food lottery stay
tuned to see the most perfect avocado in
the world you'll have to watch this
video until the end just in case it
brings you good luck if you love food as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up
today we're showing you ten times people
absolutely won the food lottery the
giant chip you know that today is a
happy day if you are eating Lay's there
are many reasons why you could be eating
potato chips maybe you're just enjoying
a day off in front of the TV or you
could be hanging out at a party with
your friends but unfortunately those
precious yellow bags are mostly full of
air it became such a problem that people
are using it to create funny pictures
with the power of lays astronauts can
safely breathe when they are in space
and hot-air balloons can rise up in the
sky that might be a little thing that we
don't like about these chips but did you
know that there is actually a good
reason why potato chip bags are always
half empty that's because an air cushion
prevents them from becoming potato
crumbs and it's not any kind of air
oxygen would spoil the potatoes and the
humidity and normal air would make them
soggy this is why the bags are full of
nitrogen so thank you air now are you
ready to see the winner of the lottery
this person found the biggest potato
chip in the world look at that we just
hope they'll find more in the bag the
chip is so big that there is probably
nothing else left but nitrogen in that
bag of lays the yellow skittles we all
love the taste of the rainbow these
little candies know exactly how to make
us feel better during the previews at
the movies or during a party with our
friends there is just something about
all these colors that always makes us
want to smile but do you want to hear a
story about skittles that will make you
happier we all know that the rainbow is
associated with the LGBTQ community and
in 2016 in London skittles wanted to
make sure that all the attention was on
them the company explained that this
weekend they were giving up their
rainbow but no one would have to worry
because they would still be there to
celebrate every colorful minute and they
surprised everyone by showing up with
white candies instead during the parade
they handed out a limited edition of
white bags with black lettering
containing the tasty white candies they
also appeared in an all-white float the
more company's support the LGBT
community the better and we just love
this daring idea
but it seems like someone found another
fun limited-edition skittles this time
the candies are all yellow what a
pleasing surprise we just hope that
yellow is their favorite color because
they have a lot to eat that's what we
call a pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow the super strawberry now is the
time to get a little healthy and fruits
are the best thing in the world when we
want to stay in shape and eat something
sweet strawberries are perfect in the
morning for breakfast in a smoothie
before yoga class in the afternoon or in
a chocolate fondue with your lover at
night talking about love do you know
that strawberries are a popular
aphrodisiac the legend says that the
fruit originated from the heart-shaped
tiers of Aphrodite when she learned that
her lover passed away ancient Greeks
also forbade the eating of red fruits
which made people believe that
strawberries could be hiding great
powers but now that we are in the 21st
century let's hear what dr. hoppy has to
say they say that strawberries are
loaded with vitamin C which is important
for the production of love hormones and
chemical neurotransmitters in the brain
increasing libido so now you know what
you should eat for dessert on your next
date and as we can see one person really
did get lucky there is so much more to
love with this super strawberry we could
even say that it is shaped a little bit
like a heart we hope that this person
shared the fruit with their partner
because you know that this is true love
when you can give a beautiful fruit like
that to someone else the double pepper
don't underestimate the bell peppers
many of your favorite meals wouldn't be
the same without them and they always
add a little color to our plate it is
surprising to see vegetables that are so
colourful and you will be surprised to
hear that it's because bell peppers are
actually fruits according to botanists a
fruit is the part of the plant that
develops from a flower and contains
seeds the other parts of the plant are a
vegetable so according to this theory a
lot of our favorite veggies are actually
fruits we already knew about tomatoes
but cucumbers avocados pumpkins nuts and
grains are also fruits real vegetables
include celery broccoli carrots and
potatoes and actually it makes sense as
fruits are sweeter than vegetables just
like the bell peppers but there is one
person that was more surprised than you
are right now it is the one that found
the magic double pepper when you think
about it it is a little bit strange that
they were eating this fruit like an
apple but everything happens for a
reason and this is why they discovered a
pepper of another color hiding inside it
do you want more fun pepper facts to
blow your mind these fruits can also be
white black brown or purple who said the
bell peppers were not interesting the
long marshmallow this treat is the
perfect thing to eat outside around a
campfire and everyone has a different
way to eat their marshmallows some
people think that they know the best way
to roast a marshmallow and will tell
everyone about their best tips others
just want to see that thing burn and eat
this perfect disaster and there is
always someone who gives up and just
eats it raw because there's not enough
place around the campfire if you want a
story to tell your friends while they're
all around you outside tell them about
where the marshmallows come from first
you'll be surprised to know that the
marshmallow is actually a plant and
2,000 years ago it was used in medicine
even Hippocrates used it to remedy blood
loss and bruises and he is not the only
one as people all around the world use
the marshmallow plant for different
treatments we don't know if it really
worked but it is still funny to think
that it was used this way but now we can
at least say that it can actually cure a
sad face and turn it into a smile and
this person was probably happier when
they found a unique marshmallow in their
bag we think that they will have a hard
time roasting this one perfectly the
vending machine if you thought that
money couldn't buy happiness
you'll be surprised to hear that vending
machines give away smiles for two
dollars yes we know that we're paying
too much for these chocolates or those
chips but when there's nothing else
around we know that it is worth it there
is no better motivation than treating
yourself to a bar of chocolate during a
long day at work but unfortunately
vending machines are not always as good
as you think sometimes your bag of chips
get stuck in there and don't ever try to
shake the machine to get it it could
fall on you and crush you it wouldn't be
the first time that someone has to go to
the hospital because of this as two
people passed away every year in the
United States alone but trying to tilt
faulty vending machines if you really
want your bag of chips just ask the
person responsible for the machine or
buy something on top of it to make it
fall on it but don't worry too much
vending machines can really be nice too
and this is what this person found out
when they saw this gift from heaven this
time all the chips had fallen at the
same time and they were ready for this
person to eat them it's a dream come
true
the big blueberries there are never
enough of this fruit we buy some at the
grocery store and by the time we get
home we already ate everything
we just love eating berries and don't
worry this time blueberries are truly
berries instead we'll surprise you by
telling you that there are probably the
only berries that you can identify
that's because strawberries raspberries
and blackberries are not real berries no
matter what their name is people started
calling
berries before scientists could clearly
define what it is and the new definition
is far more complex than a small squishy
fruit that we can pick up from plants
according to Judy churns debt a
professor of plant science at the
University of California a berry is made
of three layers the outer skin
the fleshy middle and the part which
holds the seeds moreover the fruit must
come from a flower with one ovary that's
more complicated than what we thought so
what are berries
you'll be surprised to know that you
already ate many of them because bananas
watermelons oranges grapes and eggplants
are berries scientifically speaking this
person was lucky enough to find many
real berries and we can't believe that
they're so big with giant berries like
that you only need these five to satisfy
your hunger we just hope that they won't
accidentally swallow the money to the
little surprise we have to admit that
Kinder Surprise eggs were our favorite
chocolate when we were kids we didn't
have to choose between milk chocolate or
white chocolate we had both in one and
as soon as we opened it we discovered a
little toy unfortunately many children
in the United States will never have the
chance to live that dream
that's because Kinder Surprise eggs are
illegal there since 1938 the country
banned all the candies with
non-nutritive objects in them so since
they began to be manufactured in Italy
in the 70s they never had the chance to
enter the United States at least not
legally according to the National Post
60000 Kinder Surprise eggs were
confiscated at the border in 2011 people
can receive fines of up to $1,200 per
egg but the country claims that the toys
are still too dangerous to children to
be imported legally you can still buy
something similar the choco treasure
eggs that are safer for children but
this non American was probably luckier
than any other kid because they found a
better surprise inside their kinder
there was another chocolate egg ready to
be eaten as grown-ups we would love to
see just more chocolate instead of the
toy inside the egg and it would also be
a great way to make Kinder Surprise
legal in the United States let's call
the company right now the perfect
watermelon now that we know that it's a
berry it's probably our favorite one
it's the perfect fruit for summer as
there is enough to share with all our
friends and it helps us stay hydrated
but did you know that watermelons didn't
always look like that they had to be
genetically modified over a millennium
to look like this at that time we
weren't splicing genes from other
organisms but used selectively breeding
instead and we bet that you can't wait
to see the result in this picture from
the 17th
tree you can see a watermelon that looks
really different from those we eat
nowadays as you can see the Barry has
swirly shapes in six triangular pieces
Giovanni stanky was a great painter so
we know that he didn't make a mistake
here that's actually what he saw in
front of him but we really do prefer the
watermelons that we see nowadays with
their red fleshy interior and one person
had the chance to find the final result
of selective breeding the perfect
watermelon just look at this beauty
there's barely any seeds and it's also
cut perfectly and we can't believe that
they found a way not to spill water
everywhere when cutting it a perfect
fruit like that deserves to be shared
with everyone so please give us a piece
the magic avocado
here's another berry that we all love it
has become so popular that grown-ups
complain that millenials are buying
expensive avocado toasts instead of
buying houses but we know that when we
have to live in an apartment these
fruits can at least be a source of
comfort they're also really healthy
actually an avocado has more potassium
than a banana about twice as much it is
also the fruit that has the most protein
which could explain why vegetarians
liked it so much it is also better than
what you can find in meat as the body
can use all the protein in this fruit
you can also swap butter for avocados
and baked good recipes to make your
cookies or your brownies healthier
however if there is one thing that we
don't like about avocados it's the big
seed in the middle when you buy an
avocado you always have to think that
you'll only be eating half of it because
of that but the winner of the food
lottery had a pleasant surprise
they had the chance to find a seedless
avocado and we can't think of anything
else that could make their day better
did you ever win the food lottery -
don't be shy to tell us what happened in
the comment section down below we'd love
to hear what you think and that's it for
ten times people absolutely won the food
lottery if you want to see more stories
like this make sure you watch ten gummy
foods that taste better than real food
thanks for watching
[Music]